[Musique]
oh
la décision a été prise ce matin même
que la saison des pèlerinages kid
habituellement a lieu du 1er avril au
1er novembre serait reporté jusqu'au 8
décembre qui est la fête de l'immaculée
conception
et puisque les pèlerins ne peuvent plus
venir jusqu'à nous nous nous avons
décidé d'aller vers eux et donc depuis
avant même le confinement d'ailleurs
dans cette grotte juste derrière moi les
chapelains stern les prêtres et les
religieux qui sont au service du
sanctuaire se succèdent pour une prise
ininterrompue du matin 7 heures jusqu'au
soir 20h30
[Musique]
nous serons certainement amenés à faire
appel aussi à la générosité de tous les
fidèles et de tous les amoureux de
lourdes pour que ce sanctuaire puisse
repartir pour qu'il puisse accueillir
encore mieux parce que vous tout le
monde se rend bien compte que nous
n'avons plus aucune ressource
aujourd'hui pour faire vivre notre
sanctuaire
[Musique]